.
>> Dana: AUTHORITIES ARE
GIVING AN UPDATE ON AN UNFOLDING
TRAGEDY IN FLORIDA, RESCUE
WORKERS DESPERATELY SCOURING THE
RUBBLE OF A 12 STORY BUILDING
THAT SUDDENLY COLLAPSED AROUND
1:30 A.M., AUTHORITY SAYING AT
LEAST 99 RESIDENTS ARE STILL
UNACCOUNTED FOR BUT THERE IS
STILL HOPE FOR SURVIVORS AS YOU
JUST HEARD FROM OFFICIALS THERE.
STEVE HARRIGAN IS AT THE SCENE
IN SURFSIDE, HE'S BEEN THERE
SINCE THIS MORNING, DEEP, CAN
YOU GIVE US AN UPDATE AS TO
WHERE WE ARE NOW?
>> DANA, I THINK THE KEY
HEADLINE COMING OUT OF THAT
PRESS CONFERENCES THERE ARE
STILL SOUNDS COMING FROM THE
RUBBLE.
IT IS NOT CLEAR THAT THAT SOUND
IS COMING FROM HUMANS, IT IS A
BANGING, THEY ARE NOT SURE WHERE
IT'S COMING FROM, NO HUMAN
VOICES INVOLVED BUT THERE IS A
SOUND AND FOR OFFICIALS HERE AS
WELL AS THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA
THIS IS STILL VERY MUCH A SEARCH
AND RESCUE OPERATION.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT MUCH OF
THAT WORK, MUCH OF THE EFFORT TO
RESCUE PEOPLE IS GOING ON
UNDERNEATH THE SURFACE, UNDER
THE PARKING GARAGE.
IT IS THERE THAT THEY ARE
CUTTING, DRILLING, DIGGING,
WORKING WITH DOGS, TUNNELING
THROUGH TO TRY TO FIND AND
RESCUE ANYONE SO MUCH OF THE
WORK GOING ON UNDERGROUND AND
STILL SOME HOPE AS URBAN SEARCH
AND RESCUE TEAMS CONTINUE TO
WORK THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT
TONIGHT TO TRY TO RESCUE AS MANY
AS 99 PEOPLE WILL UNACCOUNTED
FOR.
DANA?
>> Dana: STEVE, WE ARE GOING
TO TAKE IT AROUND THE TABLE
HERE, YOU ARE WATCHING
"THE FIVE" AND WE WILL TAKE IT
TO QUESTIONS NOW, KATIE, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO START, DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION?
>> Katie: ARE THERE ANY
UPDATES ON THE BUILDING AND WHAT
CAUSED THIS?
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING AT THIS AND SAYING, HOW
COULD THIS POSSIBLY HAPPEN,
ESPECIALLY IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT WHEN PEOPLE ARE SLEEPING?
>> CERTAINLY THE MAYOR OF
SURFSIDE IS SAYING, THIS IS A
BIZARRE, ON A SCALE OF 1 TO 10
THIS IS TEN, IT SHOULDN'T
HAPPEN, IT COULDN'T HAPPEN,
THAT'S ONE EXTREME.
FLORIDA INTERNATIONAL UNIVERSITY
INVESTIGATOR SAYING THAT THIS
BUILDING HAS BEEN SINKING AT
2 MILLIMETERS A YEAR SINCE THE
1990s, THERE'S BEEN A LAWSUIT
BY RESIDENTS OF THE BUILDING FOR
CRACKS IN THE BUILDING, LEAKAGE
FROM THE POOL, CONSTRUCTION ON
THE BUILDING, MAJOR CONSTRUCTION
NEXT TO THE BUILDING.
RIGHT NOW ALL WE HAVE IS
THEORIES WHY POSSIBLY THIS
TRAGEDY COULD HAVE OCCURRED BUT
NO CLEAR ANSWER YES TO WHAT
CAUSED THE COLLAPSE.
>> Dana: GERALDO, ANY COMMENT
ON THAT OR A QUESTION?
>> Geraldo: I THINK THE
INVESTIGATION WILL REVEAL WHAT I
FEAR WILL BE SOMETHING MUCH MORE
WIDESPREAD, THESE BUILDINGS
BUILT ON SAND, YOU KNOW, THEY
SINK, THINGS HAPPENING BUT EVE,
THE QUESTION I HAVE FOR YOU,
THIS SEEMS, EVERYONE IS SO
MEASURED IN THEIR REMARKS.
THIS TEAMS TO MAKE SEEMS TO ME
AN UNFOLDING CATASTROPHE, IF 99E
ARE
STILL UNACCOUNTED FOR, WE ARE
HEARING THE OFFICIALS SPEAK OF
SOUNDS OF BANGING HERE OR THERE
BUT THAT BUILDING AS I
UNDERSTAND IT PANCAKE SO THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF SPACE IN THE
BUILDING THAT HAS COLLAPSE, IS
THERE A SENSE OF THAT, IS THERE
A SENSE THAT THIS IS A TRAGEDY
OF REALLY SIGNIFICANT
PROPORTIONS?
>> I THINK WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN
THERE YET, I THINK THERE IS
STILL HOPE AND TREMENDOUS FEAR
AND ANXIETY BUT THE FACT THAT IT
COULD BE 99 HAS NOT SET IN HERE
YET AND YOU ARE RIGHT TO POINT
OUT, THE DESTRUCTION IS
INCREDIBLE, WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT
IT'S NOT JUST THE EDGE OF THIS
BUILDING THAT WAS RIPPED AWAY,
IT WAS ROUGHLY HALF OF 136
CONDOMINIUM UNITS AND THE
PANCAKE ITSELF OF RUBBLE IS
ABOUT THREE STORIES HIGH WITH NO
SPACE IN BETWEEN SO IT'S A
DEVASTATING SCENE, HARD TO
IMAGINE PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
THERE, THEY DID RESCUE 36
OVERNIGHT BUT JUST TWO PULLED
FROM THE RUBBLE.
>> Dana: JESSE?
>> Jesse: I HAVE A COMMENT, I
SPOKE TO A BUILDER TODAY WHO
SAID THAT CRACK HAD TO HAVE BEEN
VISIBLE AND NOW YOU ARE HEARING
PEOPLE SAY THERE IS A LITIGATION
OVER CRACKS AND BECAUSE IT WAS A
PANCAKE IT ONLY MEANS ONE THING,
THIS BUILDING HAD TO HAVE BEEN
BUILT STRUCTURALLY WRONG AND
THAT'S ON THE ARCHITECT, THE
DEVELOPER AND THE CONTRACTOR AND
IF THEY HAVE A REVIEW EVERY 40
YEARS, THEY WERE IN THE REVIEW
PROCESS TO PASS THE INSPECTION,
THE REPORTING IS THAT THEY WERE
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT MAKING
STRUCTURAL CHANGES IN ORDER TO
PASS INSPECTION AND IF YOU ADD
THAT TO THE "USA TODAY" REPORT
THAT SAYS THERE WAS A SURVEY
DONE IN THE '90s THAT SAYS THE
STRUCTURE WAS SINKING, YOU HAVE
TO ASK YOURSELF, WHEN DID THE
ASSOCIATION KNOW ABOUT THIS AND
IF THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT YOU ARE GOING TO SEE ONE OF
THE BIGGEST LAWSUITS IN FLORIDA
HISTORY BECAUSE ITS NEGLIGENT
HOMICIDE AND THAT'S REALLY THE
KEY TO THIS IS KNOWING WHEN
THESE STRUCTURAL IMBALANCES WERE
AND DOING NOTHING ABOUT IT AND
THAT IS JUST A HORRIBLE,
HORRIBLE TRAGE